from the first day that Donald Trump's
Attorney General William Barr released
his four-page letter about the molar
report on the Trump investigation any
thinking person realized that it did not
accurately represent the content of the
molar report there was conflicting
legalese there was a sort of
deliberately mixed up use of words like
establish versus find it read like a
political document because that's what
it was not sort of a sober honest law
enforcement assessment and then once the
Muller report was published this was
confirmed the molar report is truly
devastating to Donald Trump and it has
sparked this huge impeachment movement
within the Democratic Party that we've
been talking about but a question that
kept coming up including from people who
would call me during live calls was if
Robert Muller really felt that the bar
letter was not an honest representation
of the report that it was deceptive in
some way wouldn't we have heard publicly
from Robert Muller and my answer at the
time and it remains my answer is no
Moeller kept quiet the entire
investigation save for like one or two
statements that were made through his
spokesperson so I wouldn't expect Robert
Muller to come out guns blazing and
loudly and publicly saying William Barr
is being deceptive but last night in a
just blockbuster story in The Washington
Post
we learned that Robert Muller actually
does think that the bar characterization
of his report was dishonest and he
privately contacted William Barr to tell
him this and this is the strongest
indictment yet of the cover-up act that
William bar has participated in and it's
studying but also not surprising because
we suspected all along that this was
exactly the situation The Washington
Post has learned of both a letter and a
phone call from Robert Muller to William
Barr the letter component was sent to
William Barr on March 27th and in this
letter Robert Muller complained that the
four-page memo or as I call it a
propaganda letter which was written by
William Barr quote
did not fully capture the context nature
and substance of Robert molars
investigation exactly as I told you it
was deceptive it was incomplete it was
calculated it lacked contacts it was
dishonest and it was primarily dishonest
in that as a general as a general sort
of concept it framed the Moller report
as exonerating Trump totally and
completely which it didn't actually do
this letter that Robert Muller sent to
William bar reportedly shocked senior
Justice Department officials that a
special prosecutor would be in such
disagreement with the public statements
of William bar about his investigation
that he wrote a letter in these terms
with this language to the Attorney
General the letter is devastating but it
confirms every single one of our
suspicions here's just one piece of it
that I want to put up on the screen and
read to you quote the summary letter the
department sent to Congress and released
to the public late in the afternoon of
March 24 did not fully capture the
context nature and substance of this
office's work in conclusions there is
now public confusion about critical
aspects of the results of our
investigation this threatens to
undermine a central purpose for which
the department appointed the special
counsel to assure full public confidence
in the outcome of the investigations and
Muller is completely right he spent two
years investigating he found to quote
the report substantial evidence of
Donald Trump obstructing justice found
all sorts of wrongdoing by Trump and
people around him and William Bar by
putting out this four-page propaganda
letter about the probe a dishonest
letter undermines the whole point of
even having the investigation you didn't
need an investigation if either way the
Attorney General was going to say Trump
is cleared and he's effectively the
victim here and we now know that Robert
Moeller's letter was followed up by a
phone call which reportedly lasted about
15 minutes
that's one phone call I would love to
hear a recording of and again during the
call Moeller said media coverage of the
report as a result of the letter you put
out is misguided and it
creating public misunderstandings of
what the findings actually are and the
most important takeaway from all of this
as unsurprising as it is is that this
was the plan all along it worked the
whole point of installing bar after
temporarily having Matthew Whitaker
running the Justice Department of having
Barr put this letter out before the
report so that the media exoneration
tour could be done by Trump and
right-wing media and even some in
left-wing media this was all meant to
prime the pump for people to say no
collusion no obstruction forget about it
I told you that this was the plan all
along from the moment Matthew Whitaker
was put in there and Robert Millar
saying this only confirms it and most
Americans will never read the Moller
report they knew that the bar letter
would set the tone and the content for
most Americans it's very difficult to
fight against that right now
conservative bill kristol
with whom I agree like I I agree with
him basically never he actually had a
pretty good take about this on Twitter
last night he said quote molars report
read without bars coloring invites the
house to at least consider impeachment
now that bars coloring has been as it
were erased how can the White House
avoid its responsibilities what's at
this point to be gained by trying
fastidiously to avoid the dread word I
believe he means the dreaded word how
does Bill Kristol become the voice of
reason and then the the next question is
what now
Moeller needs to testify we have to hear
from Muller we have to hear from molars
prosecutors who said more than a year
ago that they determined Donald Trump
did obstruct justice but for political
reasons dropped the idea of indicted him
and there are now Democrats also
considering impeachment of William bar
over what they feel accurately is
William bar having hugely misread misled
Congress when he previously testified
we'll find out what happens in his
testimony today the right and Trump were
hoping that the molar report was the
beginning of the end I hope that this is
only the start of the middle game
because there are only
more problems rising that are going to
need to be dealt with I don't know if
anybody's going to face consequences
here I really don't for all of this
wrongdoing but people should and I hope
that Democrats will have both the
backbone but also the political will to
make sure that people are held
accountable I am thrilled to tell you
that today's episode is sponsored in
part by Blink asam / Pakman blink astiz
a really unique service for your phone
tablet and web browser and it is
incredibly useful for people like me who
love books and learning but are busy
blinka stakes the best and most popular
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks I'm sure that
if you're like me you have a very long
list of books that you've been meaning
to read you only have so many hours in
the day and that's why blink astiz so
amazing they take the most important
information the themes the insights from
each book and they distill it into a 15
minute audio book that you can listen to
in one sitting I've listened to a ton of
books on blankets our audience can get a
7 day free trial by going to blink is
calm / Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the
description I have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about 5 bucks a month go
to blink is calm / Pakman that's B Li NK
is t.com /pa ke ma n